welcome to this video playing G rome i
think i recently lost the first game
against him after couple of wins and was
it this line I think you to pee really
possible yeah let's be quick yeah that
looks like a completely standard iqp
position sure therefore I don't know
what is this idea should be five
something like that maybe know this one
okay take stakes 95 it looks like a
whole bunch of trades okay
push a three maybe set the idea okay
that's very much possible yeah that
might be an idea indeed I think he wants
to play no I thought looks you one at
the end but that's an also leading
nowhere i have Bishop c5 I don't see
much benefit their provide the only
thing is that who of course this is just
not very exciting so like King to e6
would be good can also play each five
and g5 toronto maybe this is an idea g5
and then King up to F 526 yeah let's do
this medium and this gives some let's
add some ideas to the pollution okay now
is he maybe wants to go e cigs look what
about Ruth will see one Rock d7 ok let's
at least somewhat interesting I don't
know what to make of it maybe I'm worse
even but as a status interesting
check hmm King up what is the idea yeah
rook age six maybe hmm is rook is very
active the way I played this was of
course somewhat provocative s'ok age six
movement if I go g4 gauge success what
I'm talking about maybe
hmm
that's difficult to to do much or about
anything at all for that matter Bishop
c5 has regev six mate this is
particularly particularly bad so okay
I'm shuffling a bit here maybe he's got
some idea what to do him
yeah that you could get out of the sea
files of course a huge drawback of my of
my idea there with h 5 g fo and so on
probably not great what I did them
hmm six ok 604 that's really awful not
sure about a six maybe it's good yeah
something like Group C 8b 8b seven or so
and then I have kinky sex my unknown
know maybe maybe that's good that
position must be really really critical
for me if not losing somehow Bishop
takes b6 is also a huge issue Wow he
wants his he wants to play it like a
pure magician so he's saying that I
cannot stop a 74 maybe I cannot
okay contiki 5 has got a 87 I cannot get
I have no way to get to the
eighth-ranked amazing time morning yep
not much to do and maybe who here very
nice with that rook sucker for us but I
don't really know if that was necessary
it doesn't look clear to me really if
white wins maybe he does somehow but
right now I don't see exactly how
check check hmm somewhat tricky but not
sure if it loses I think he was once a
drawing on this is no bad for me gets to
e6 and shoot is the right bishop as well
check mark in black resigns huh cheers
oh maybe this wasn't then a good idea i
don't know i like that yet was kind of
ambitious but maybe it was too much rook
c1 really that was a problem and I mean
okay I of course i saw that i can go
look cata but I gent want that I wanted
more a bit more attention well he just
places and gave me this is just very
Jewish I wanted to do I wanted to be
more active but this is really not a
good idea here yeah he is just better
and it I mean okay rook takes b6 was I
think
the unnecessary but it may be maybe it
was good i mean he could have played
normal stuff like g4 or something it is
also given by the engine with that with
the wind yeah I cannot move here and so
he just so passer like this and
something here yeah I don't know that I
think that this might be a draw him but
it'sit's of course very awkward to
defend and I thought that this might be
in the wrong but not not really not sure
check check check there are no one lost
illnesses check was good I have to play
King hear the engine seized no way
forward I am not really sure would you
to analyze this a bit deeper but yeah
yeah yeah I'm loosely he just enters
that there's no way no way to save it
yeah I have to be less ambitious than
and prevent the Roxy one business here
here's a key moment we go rook c8 is
this fine I'm just keeping um yeah I'm
keeping control of the CFR and then not
much happens okay well thanks for
watching